over the weekend guardians of the galaxy  star dave batista shared a video of a  severely neglected puppy at the humane  society of tampa bay now the actor has  revealed in a new video posted to his  instagram that not only has he adopted  her into his pack he is offering a  reward that has been matched by the  humane society and some famous friends  like the walking dead star jeffrey dean  morgan for any information that leads to  the arrest of the puppy's previous owner  take a look  the good news is today  the puppy you know as sage  actually became  penny batista so i'd like to introduce  you the newest member of my family  oh and there she is healing up nice and  recovered  she is now a batista and she will never  be abused again a day in her life not a  second in her life she's  about to live her best puppy life ever  so anyway thank you guys for helping us  out and that's the update is uh  sage is now penny batista and she has  her forever home